bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 26 avril
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal votre
actualité locale sur saint quentin en
yvelines et pour ouvrir cette édition ou
revenu en images sur l'accident qui a eu
lieu hier sur l'a13 l'accident s'est
déroulé au niveau de la sortie des
mureaux dans les yvelines vers 13h neuf
personnes étaient touchées dont deux
blessés graves deux poids lourds et six
autres véhicules ont été impliqués pour
une raison encore inconnue l'un des deux
poids lourds a traversé le terre plein
central et percuté les véhicules vous
voyez sur les images ça c'est
impressionnant
un important dispositif de sécurité de
secours a été déployé
vingt véhicules du service départemental
d'incendié et de secours avec 60
pompiers et quatre véhicules du samu
l'autoroute a été réouverte aux environs
de 19h et politiques à présent le
président du sénat gérard larcher tête
ont vite à bois d'arcy hier après midi
nous en avions parlé
l'homme politique et le maire de la
commune philippe benassaya se sont
rendus dans deux des entreprises de la
ville située dans le quartier de la
croix bonnet une visite pour évoquer les
thèmes de la formation et des métiers de
demain
un reportage signé michael et demi
d'euros et sephora mamani formation et
innovation deux mots clés de la venue de
gérard larcher président du sénat à bois
d'arcy lundi 25 avril
au programme visite de deux des 70
entreprises de la zone arcisienne
delacroix bonnet première étape la
plateforme de service après vente du
groupe hn est implanté sur le site
depuis 2012 c'est un bassin où les les
chiffres de l'emploi sont plutôt bons et
font rêver
dans le reste du pays c'est en même
temps on le voit bien une période qui
n'est pas facile où les communautés
d'agglo doivent se battre pour le
développement économique
lacroix boon est un grand centre
économique pour bonnart 6 avec des
fleurons industriels
hilti leroy merlin leclercdrive boiron
voilà ce sont des grandes entreprises
suite à un incendie des locaux hilti de
magny les hameaux en 2012 l'entreprise a
choisi bois d'arcy pour reconstruire ses
9000 m² dédiés au service après vente
la structure est intégré un centre de
formation national afin d'accompagner au
mieux les mille quatre cent cinquante
salariés dits petits france le service à
présent c'est très important pour nous
c'est un des services qui différencie de
la concurrence et donc c'est un lieu
d'expertisé aussi et donc on s'est dit
on va mettre la formation même endroit
voulait pas de formation hors sol
l'information qu'ils soient loin du
terrain loin des préoccupations
opérationnelle des facteurs de la
compétitivité c'est la formation
initiale c'est la formation
je crois que c'est une des forces
notamment de l'économie allemande
il y en a d'autres éléments mais la
formation initiale nous n'avons pas
encore résolu tout à fait cela dans
notre pays
la visite s'est ensuite poursuivie au
leclerc drive situe également à la croix
ball est une structure implantée sur
bois d'arcy depuis 2014
gérard larcher a ensuite conclu sa
visite par une rencontre avec les élus
de la majorité municipale
prenons à présent la direction de
plaisir l'association plaisir jeunesse
va disparaître d'ici le 31 mai les sept
éducateurs de rue qui travaillaient au
sein du club de prévention spécialisée
vont être licenciés la raison de cette
fermeture
le non renouvellement des conventions
liant le département et la municipalité
à l'association une pétition rassemblant
environ 400 signatures a été mise en
ligne
même si l'avenir des salariés est déjà
scellé un reportage signé william l
c'est la fin d'une histoire qui durait
depuis 1975 le 31 mai prochain
l'association plaisir jeunesse aura mis
la clé sous la porte
la clôture des conventions qui dit lié
au département et à la municipalité
mettra un terme à l'action de ce club de
prévention spécialisée
normalement c'est des jeunes d'entre de
dix à vingt cinq ans la relation de
confiance c'est la base de notre travail
ces jeunes et du coup quand ils ont ils
rencontrent des problèmes dans leur
parcours de vie mais il vient vers les
éducateurs ou les éducateurs dont
congénères en faisant le travail de rue
ils peuvent rencontrer dans leurs
quartiers dans leur milieu
du coup voilà donc des contacts de liens
qui se créent à partir de là il ya des
accompagnements qui sème en place sur
2000 15 175 jeunes ont été soutenus par
les sept éducateurs de l'association
parmi eux le fils dodi va qui a
récemment lancé une pétition de soutien
on n'a pas beaucoup le temps des parents
parfois et ça nous a quand même idée et
c'est agréable
ne serait-ce que de prendre un verre à
la maison café et discuter avec eux
dirai ce que s'est passé avec les
enfants 6 à 20 difficulté ne dit c'est
ça nous a mis en confiance en a mis en
confiance
en 2015 500 mille euros était versée par
le département et 130 me par la commune
de plaisir pour le maire la fin de la
convention est dictée par le nouveau
mode de fonctionnement de la
municipalité
aujourd'hui nous avons mis en place à
plaisir une convention est un contrat
plutôt globale sur l'ensemble de la vie
de solidarité avec à l'intérieur la
politique de la ville avec la réussite
éducative avec toute une série d'actions
et nous avons mis en place une dizaine
de médiateurs qui sont des médiateurs
qui aujourd'hui travail en
transversalité avec les associations les
conseils de quartier pour l'élu c'est
apporter aux habitants une nouvelle
approche pour l'association le problème
de compétence est posée une
complémentarité des médiateurs et des
éducateurs serait nécessaire il est
temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique avec william l
bonsoir williams vous êtes avec moi ce
soir en plateau pour parler du projet
une vitesse donc tout à fait bonsoir
fort alors pendant une guerre chaque
camp choisi ces armes certains font le
choix de la haine et de la violence
quand d'autres choisissent l'amour et la
musique et c'est cette deuxième option
qu'on choisit des fouineurs et
anne-sophie bavent membres de
l'association à cazes alors un petit mot
sur des cahiers l'heure qu'il est c'est
un homme aux multiples facettes
il est chef d'orchestre producteur de
musique et surtout réalisateur du projet
unités qu'est ce que c'est que le projet
unité c'est une initiative lancée par
l'association a case
ils ont un studio qui se trouve à
villepreux ils ont décidé de créer un
collectif nommé ras connexion nous
sommes allés rencontrer dave dans son
studio qui nous a expliqué l'objectif du
projet race connexion est né du la
presse 13 novembre
en fait je pense que comme toute
personne sensible vous avez été
bouleversé par tout ce qui s'est passé
et c'était naturel de vouloir faire
quelque chose dire quelque chose
exprimer ce que je ressentais par
rapport à un modèle de vie par rapport à
tout ce qui était construit et que des
personnes mal intentionnées veulent
détruire
donc l'idée c'était vraiment de réunir
tout un collectif d'artistes de talent
de la mouvance reggae ragga dancehall et
afin d'exprimer notre notre unité pour
défendre nos valeurs
un septième moyens mais ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur le
collectif
bien sûr alors ce qu'on peut dire
surtout c'est que ça donne l'eau à la
bouche
ça c'est un projet qui réunit 34
chanteur huit musiciens de toute la
scène reggae ragga dance hall avec des
têtes d'affiché comme le backing band de
tiken jah fakoly colocks princess erika
ou encore brahim les gens passent
évidemment beaucoup d'autres alors tous
ces gens là sont rassemblés sur une
seule chanson qui s'appelle unités vous
allez me dire réunir autant de
personnalités sur un seul projet c'est
quasiment mission impossible
ils ont commencé un peu après les
attentats et ils ont mis plusieurs
semaines pour arriver à tout enregistrer
mais dave qui est musicien avait déjà un
bon carnet d adresses pardon et quand
c'est pour la bonne cause ça va beaucoup
plus vite
nous avons travaillé déjà deux un
premier set très restreinte donc avec
mon binôme enso qui nous occupons de
l'association de faisant tourner
l'association est là
nous avons de quoi écrire les paroles et
la musique est comme de soupe un grand
chanteur j'ai fait après la une de mes
amies qui est qu'il allait qui je
travaille auprès d'amundi qui j'ai
chanté la mélodie et puis qui a qui
l'art qu'il a arrangé qu'il a bien
structuré et nous avons nous avons
envoyé les markets
la maquette à tous les chanteurs dont
chacun sait exactement ce qu'il avait à
faire et les us cling cling données
fondamentales unité c'est donc une
chanson qui rend hommage à toutes les
victimes d'attentats à travers le monde
mais c'est surtout un message est une
réponse à l'oppression terroristes et à
leur volonté de provoquer cas aux
divisions et n
mais surtout ce qu'on ressent c'est
l'implication d'edf dans son combat
lorsqu'il nous en parle
nous sommes tous français nous aimons
voir d un moment j'ai notamment faire
l'amour nous allons sortir nous aimons
la musique regarder la télé parle entre
amis manger ce qu'ils mangent et en une
grande tradition culinaire ici envie
d'un pays où il ya un grand métissage
dont commence la musique on mange le de
l'africain de de la cuisine thaïlandaise
chinoise tout ce que vous voulez
antillaise et tout ça c'est nous tout ça
c'est nourrir veut nous faire croire que
non que nous sommes le mal non c'est pas
possible on tient tout ça tout ça est
juste quand l'outil en musique
alors cette chance unités ou est-ce
qu'on peut l'écouter
alors elle est sortie le 20 avril et
pour dave et anne-sophie c'est
certainement le début d'une grande
aventure
pas la peine de dire que tous les
artistes ont collaboré collaborer
bénévolement au projet la chanson unité
elle est disponible pour l'instant sur
youtube sous le nom de unité ras
connexion elle est gratuite et libre de
droit est l'objectif du collectif c'est
qu'elle soit diffusée
un maximum tout le monde est invité à la
partager et c'est d'ailleurs ce que je
vous invite à faire en vous rendant sur
youtube pour aller regardez vous même le
clip et on va se quitter en diffusant un
court extrait parce que un court extrait
vaut mieux qu'une chronique
et passons à l'économie à présent
financer son projet d'entreprise peut
parfois être un parcours du combattant
pour les entrepreneurs pour les aider
dans leurs démarches la pépinière
d'entreprises chrysalis située à trappes
organise des ateliers
vendredi dernier c'était l'occasion
d'échanger des idées sur le financement
du projet un reportage signé fanny
bourdillon et william elle crée une
société peut se révéler compliqué
surtout quand on est isolé attrape la
pépinière d'entreprises chrysalide est
là pour apporter conseils et réseaux
professionnels aux jeunes entrepreneurs
notre rôle c'est de leur être
directement utiles en leur proposant
donc des locaux des services d'accueil
et des animations
comment vendre son projet de financement
c'est le thème de cet atelier
sept jeunes entrepreneurs sont venus
comprendre comment nous est un bon
contact avec les banques
là on a entendu le point de vue de la
cci et d'une banque qui explique comment
eux le raisonne de façon tout à fait
neutre
donc on était un peu dans leur tête et
c'est à trappes en tout cas ou dans les
yvelines où on est bien accompagné à la
maison de l'entreprise
la cci à la pépinière également qui nous
accompagne pour nous aider à mieux
mettre en place notre dossier de
financement
s'ils nous disent non c'est pas
forcément pour être déplaisant mais
c'est aussi parce que s'ils disent non
cet intérêt à reconsidérer
l'investissement partenaires de
chrysalide la chambre de commerce des
yvelines est aussi présente pour des
accompagnements individuels
l'objectif les aider à vendre leur
projet les clés à respecter c'est
effectivement être
présenter un bon dossier donc bien
parler du projet bien parlé
au-delà des chiffres d'adp à ce malaise
financière démontrer que le projet est
viable dans le temps près de 100
entreprises ont été accompagnées depuis
l'ouverture du site en 2007 et le
résultat est concluant
80% d'entre elles il dépasse les 5 ans
d'activité contre 50 % pour la moyenne
nationale
et ce week-end se tenait la
traditionnelle après real de montigny le
bretonneux à la ferme du manet en
partenariat avec la ville le lion's-club
montini les trois villages organisé
samedi et dimanche sa fête annuelle des
fleurs et des jardins
cette 13e édition était destiné à
financer la lutte contre la cécité les
bénéfices réalisés au cours de la
manifestation sont reversés pour aider à
former des chiens guides d'aveuglés à
l'école des chiens guides de paris on
écoute tout de suite alain briller
commissaire général de l'après el du
lions club de montigny le bretonneux
c'est permettre aux habitants de décorer
leur jardin d'acheter des plants c'est
la saison de planter et donc qu'on
sélectionne uniquement des producteurs
et des gens de qualité
les pépiniéristes qui vendent des choses
un petit peu rare et surtout de très
bonne qualité et qui reviennent d'année
en année et avec une clientèle de ses
fidèles et nous allons nous quitter sur
ces quelques images mais nous sommes
bien le 26 février nous on vient au
printemps et pourtant il a neigé
aujourd'hui sur saint quentin en
yvelines
un épisode neigeux qui a dit recchi a
duré peu de temps et de me vrai
normalement pas se reproduire l'aspect
le 26 avril pardon je me suis trompé
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je remercie de nous avoir suivis tout de
suite vous avez rendrez vous avec
nicolas quirion mise pour le 7-8 société
ce soir le débat portera sur la ruralité
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
un nouveau numéro du journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée